Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
No es difícil imaginar un mundo
en el que en cualquier momento dado,
Uds. y todos sus conocidos podrían
ser aniquilados sin previo aviso
con solo pulsar un botón.
Esta fue la realidad para millones
de personas durante los 45 años
tras la Segunda Guerra Mundial,
ahora conocidos como la Guerra Fría.
Mientras EE.UU. y la Unión Soviética
se enfrentaban en todo el mundo,
cada uno sabía que el otro tenía
armas nucleares capaces de destruirlo.
Y la destrucción nunca fue tan inminente
como durante los 13 días
de la crisis de los misiles en Cuba.
En 1961 EE.UU. trató de derribar sin
éxito al nuevo gobierno comunista de Cuba.
Ese intento fallido conocido
como Bahía de Cochinos,
convenció a Cuba de buscar ayuda
en la U.R.S.S.
El primer ministro soviético Nikita
Khrushchev estaba feliz de cumplir
un despliegue nuclear en secreto
de misiles a Cuba,
no solo para proteger la isla,
para contrarrestar la amenaza de misiles
estadounidenses en Italia y Turquía.
Para cuando la inteligencia
de EE.UU. descubrió el plan,
los materiales para crear los misiles
ya estaban en su lugar.
En una reunión de emergencia,
el 16 de octubre 1962,
los asesores militares pidieron un
ataque aéreo a los sitios de misiles
y la invasión de la isla.
Pero el presidente John F. Kennedy
eligió un enfoque más cuidadoso.
El 22 de octubre, anunció
que la Marina de EE.UU.
interceptaría todos los envíos a Cuba.
Hubo solo un problema:
el bloqueo naval fue considerado
un acto de guerra.
A pesar de que el presidente
lo llamó una cuarentena
que no bloqueaba las necesidades básicas,
los soviéticos no apreciaron
la distinción.
En una indignada carta a Kennedy,
Khrushchev escribió: "La violación de la
libertad de usar aguas internacionales
y espacio aéreo internacional
es un acto de agresión
que empuja a la humanidad al abismo de
una guerra mundial de misiles nucleares".
De este modo se produjeron los seis días
más intensos de la Guerra Fría.
Mientras EE.UU. exigió
la eliminación de los misiles,
Cuba y la U.S.S.R insistieron
que solo se defendían.
Y mientras se seguía cargando las armas,
EE.UU. se preparó para
una posible invasión.
El 27 de octubre, un avión espía
pilotado por el mayor Rudolph Anderson
fue derribado por un misil soviético.
El mismo día, una carga impactó
un submarino soviético nuclear
desde un buque de la Marina de EE.UU.
que intentaba hacerlo emerger.
Los comandantes del submarino, sin
poder comunicarse con la superficie,
pensaban que la guerra había comenzado y
se disponían a lanzar un torpedo nuclear.
Tres agentes debían tomar
esa decisión por unanimidad.
El capitán y el oficial político
autorizaron el lanzamiento,
pero Vasili Arkhipov,
el segundo al mando, se negó.
Su decisión salvó el día
y quizá al mundo.
Pero la crisis no había terminado.
Por primera vez en la historia,
los militares de EE.UU.
pasaron a DEFCON 2,
la disposición de defensa a un paso
de la guerra nuclear.
Con cientos de misiles nucleares
a punto de lanzarse,
el metafórico Reloj del Juicio Final
se situó en un minuto para la medianoche.
Pero la diplomacia primó.
En Washington, DC, el procurador
general Robert Kennedy
se reunió en secreto con el embajador
soviético Anatoly Dobrynin.
Tras intensas negociaciones,
llegaron a la siguiente propuesta:
EE.UU. eliminaría sus misiles
de Turquía e Italia
y prometía no invadir Cuba
a cambio de la retirada soviética
de Cuba bajo inspección de la ONU.
Una vez concluida la reunión,
Dobrynin envió un cable a Moscú
diciendo que el tiempo era esencial
y no se debía perder la oportunidad.
Y a las 9 del día siguiente,
llegó un mensaje de Khrushchev
anunciando que retirarían
los misiles soviéticos de Cuba.
La crisis había terminado.
Aunque criticado en su momento
por sus respectivos gobiernos
por negociar con el enemigo,
el análisis histórico contemporáneo
muestra gran admiración
por la capacidad de Khrushchev y Kennedy
de resolver diplomáticamente la crisis.
Pero la lección inquietante fue
que un leve error de comunicación,
un comandante en una fracción de segundo
podría haber frustrado sus esfuerzos,
de no ser por la valiente decisión
de Vasili Arkhipov.
La crisis de los misiles de Cuba reveló
lo frágiles que son los políticos humanos
en comparación con el poder aterrador
que pueden desencadenar.